[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend in einer ganzen reihe von
bundesländern gingen heute ja die schule
wieder los bis auf thüringen wollen alle
bundesländer das auch im
präsenzunterricht
thüringen hingegen hätte die schulen
lieber bis mitte januar noch ganz
geschlossen gehalten aber das ist nach
dem von der ampel koalition in berlin
geänderten infektionsschutzgesetz hier
rechtlich nicht mehr möglich und es
herrscht politische einigkeit dass es
keine generellen schulschließungen mehr
geben soll mikron hin oder her bleibt
abzuwarten wie sehr der schulbetrieb
aber durch kantinen oder infiziert das
lehrpersonal ausgedünnt wird vertreter
von eltern und lehrerschaft und auch
institutionen wie der kinderschutzbund
beklagen außerdem dass es an vielen
schulen nach wie vor an schutzmaßnahmen
und digitaler ausstattung fehlt jan
meyer beginnt sein bericht in thüringen
für die siebenjährige lotte begann der
schulbetrieb heute morgen zu hause
denn in thüringen blieben alle schulen
zu jahresbeginn geschlossen der it
manager und seine ehefrau arbeiten zwar
selbst viel im home-office der noch
hoffen sie dass die kinder so schnell
wie möglich wieder in die schule gehen
auf dem küchentisch stellen und mauer
kann sich die band dio putzen muss auch
nicht mit ins wohnzimmer nehmen uns geht
es da google aber die herausforderung
ist für eltern riesengroß durch die
geschlossenen schulen immer nach ferien
steigt die zahl der korona fälle an
schulen an nun kommt die angst vor dem
neuen omikron virus hinzu dass besonders
ansteckend ist anders als in thüringen
öffneten den brandenburg heute alle
schulen an diesem potsdamer gymnasium
blieben von den über 500 schülern nur
zwei wegen corona verdacht zu hause
für astrid thorak ist die wiederaufnahme
des präsents unterrichts dringend
notwendig das ist wichtig dass die
kinder wieder in die schule kommen und
es wurde ja auch schon mehrfach
festgestellt dass wir die kinder diese
regelmäßigkeit im tagesablauf und auch
die sozialen kontakte von enormer
wichtigkeit sind die weihnachtsferien
hatten drei tage früher begonnen mit
drei schnelltests pro woche geht es
wieder in den präsenzunterricht mit
gemischten gefühlen ich fand ziemlich
stressig um homeschooling dass er bin
ich dankbar dass wir jetzt erstmal
wieder in die schule können mittlerweile
finde ich es eigentlich nicht mehr gut
dass präsenzunterricht ist ich würde gut
finden würde der unterricht geteilt
seien einfach zu der sicherheit der
schüler schon jetzt sind die
ansteckungsraten unter schülern am
höchsten bei kindern bis 14 liegt die
aktuelle incident bei fast 3 144 im
alter bis 34 sogar bei fast 300 56 bis
59 jahren sind es aber nur rund 245 bei
über 60 jährigen sogar nur knapp 100
andererseits in deutschland blieben die
schulen länger geschlossen als anderswo
in europa damit muss schluss sein
fordern die kultusminister der
bundesländer die am mittwoch erneut
beraten man muss bedenken dass in
deutschland die schulen sehr lange
geschlossen waren während der pandemie
über 180 tage und es ist richtig und
darüber gibt es einen konsens auch
zwischen bund und ländern in der
jetzigen phase der pandemie alles dafür
zu tun dass die schulen geöffnet bleiben
können doch wie können schulen offen
bleiben und dennoch sicher sein viele
einrichtungen sind aus sicht von
elternvertretern auf die omikron welle
nicht vorbereitet wir werden einfach
höhere fallzahlen positiv getestete
schüler haben wir werden mehr positiv
getestete wehrkräfte haben wenn ich
offen und sichere schulen haben will
dann muss ich dafür auch etwas tun ich
brauch bauliche maßnahmen ich brauche
tägliche tests und all das haben wir in
bran wirklich immerhin in brandenburg
wird ab februar täglich getestet
verspricht das bildungsministerium in
thüringen dagegen bleiben die schulen
morgen noch geschlossen danach sollen
sie selbst entscheiden für familie
oehler bleibt die unsicherheit darüber
wann tochter lotte endlich wieder in die
schule gehen kann
über das thema spricht nachher im
heute-journal ab pause mit der
generalsekretärin der
bundesschülerkonferenz katharina swing
kann
auf den allerletzten drücker zwei
stunden bevor am silvesterabend das alte
jahr endete war in brüssel noch jemand
fleißig im jahresend stress sozusagen
schnell noch eine letzte e mail
raushauen die ging dann auch an alle
deutschen ministerien und präsentierte
den kommissionsvorschlag für das neue
öko label der eu im eu jargon wird das
taxonomie genannt und ist vor allem für
investoren richtig
wirklich überrascht haben kann das in
berlin eigentlich nicht die deutsche
regierung war an den diskussionen
darüber ja selbst beteiligt aber in der
öffentlichkeit wirkte es wie ein
silvesterknaller wie jetzt atomkraft und
erdgas sollen künftig als nachhaltige
grüne energiequellen firmieren
worum es geht und wie sich in berlin die
parteien dazu jetzt positionieren
berichtet andrea maurer
das ist das papier das die eu in der
neujahrsnacht verschickt hat darin der
plan atomkraft und gas als öko grün und
nachhaltig zu labeln das überraschung
und empörung in deutschland groß sind
überrascht wiederum die eu-kommission
repetieren wir haben unzählige male
wiederholt dass wir unseren vorschlag
bis jahresende vorstellen wollen
für die bundesregierung geht es nun um
die haltung wie wird sich berlin in
brüssel positionieren für die
regierungspartei der grünen geht es noch
mal um mehr um ihre dna um das wofür sie
selbst stehen öko grün nachhaltig wir
sind bei unserer position sehr klar bei
der taxonomie geht es um einen eu
standard für nachhaltige investitionen
und das jetzt atom und gas aufgenommen
werden kostet die glaubwürdigkeit das
ist eine form von greenwashing bei der
wir nicht mitgehen sollen das heißt
deutschland kann diesen vorschlag zur eu
taxonomien nicht zustimmen taxonomie
also einstufung als nachhaltige und
förderwürdige investition
einig sind sich die ampel parteien das
label für atomkraft abzulehnen uneinig
schienen sie bisher beim öko label für
erdgas für spd und fdp hielten die
grünen die aufnahme von erdgas in den
nachhaltigkeits katalog bislang für
fragwürdig bis die umweltministerin
heute nachmittag überraschend einen
neuen ton anschlägt
wir brauchen erdgas für einen begrenzten
zeitraum als brückentechnologie das ist
auch machbar die eu kommission hat ihr
kriterien vorgelegt die eine eingrenzung
auch für erdgas bedeuten diese
vorschläge müssen wir im detail noch
prüfen aber erdgas ist nicht eine
hochrisikotechnologie mit der gleichen
endlagerproblematik
koalitionsstreit runter gekocht doch
nicht alle wollen sich leise in
kompromisse fügen für die grüne jugend
geht die verrenkung zu weit in die
erzählung von sauberer oder grüner
gaskraft für eine dreckige lüge auch
dass es keine übergangstechnologie über
brückentechnologie wir brauchen jetzt
mutige und massive investitionen in
erneuerbare energien wind und solar
stadt weiter geld in fossile
energieträger zu stecken timon kinos
spricht von einem schmutzigen deal
scholz habe die taxonomie durchgewunken
weil deutschland bei der
energieversorgung noch lange auf
gaskraftwerke angewiesen sein von
absprachen ist die rede die franzosen
kriegen das grüne label für atomkraft
die deutschen das grüne label für gas
solche absprachen weiß ich nichts aber
dass man sich in dieser frage häufiger
miteinander beraten hat das habe ich
bestätigt der kanzler jedenfalls schien
schon beim eu gipfel bemüht die sache
klein zu halten vielleicht auch weil ihm
klar war wie vier konflikt sie für ihn
den selbsternannten klima kanzler und
seinen grünen koalitionspartner
bedeuten könnte
taxonomie ist ein kleines zimmer in
einer ganz großen frage wie es jetzt
weitergeht eine klage hält die
bundesregierung für weitgehend
aussichtslos eine eu mehrheit gegen die
pläne wird sich nicht finden eine
position gegenüber brüssel will die
regierung scholz nun bald festlegen
möglichst geräuschlos wie es scheint
das wollen wir doch noch vertiefen mit
unseren korrespondenten schack und allah
energy in berlin das klang jetzt fast so
als würde die bundesregierung das ganze
einfach durchwinken ja aber ganz untätig
wird sie dabei nicht zu schauen können
sonst werden nach nicht einmal vier
wochen regierungszeit zum einen die
glaubwürdigkeit in sachen klimaschutz
angeknackst und auch der
koalitionsfrieden gefährdet denn
immerhin hat sich diese bundesregierung
den ausbau der erneuerbaren energien als
ein zentrales ziel in den
koalitionsvertrag hineingeschrieben und
dann muss sie jetzt auch in brüssel hin
gehen und zumindest noch einmal
verhandeln und sich gegen die aufwertung
von atomkraft einsetzen die den
erneuerbaren energien auf dem markt der
dringend gebrauchten privatinvestitionen
jetzt konkurrenz machen würde die
bundesregierung weiß allerdings auch
dass sie dort in brüssel dann eher für
das eigene image verhandelt als für das
ergebnis denn klar ist sie hat kein
vetorecht in dieser frage und das hier
die mehrheiten in europa jetzt auf ihre
seite ziehen und gegen atomkraft als
grüne energiequelle mobilisiert das
scheint zum jetzigen zeitpunkt eher
unwahrscheinlich da schauen wir dass
auch direkt mal nach brüssel sogar über
in der tat der vorschlag der
eu-kommission der kommt ja nicht von
ungefähr sondern bildet das europäische
meinungsbild ab
ja richtig und dieses meinungsbild das
ist ungefähr so bunt wie der energiemix
in den mitgliedsstaaten es auf der einen
seite frankreich mit seinen 70 prozent
atomstrom und auf der anderen seite sind
da die osteuropäer die jetzt kurzfristig
er hat ganz brauchen um schnell aus der
noch schmutziger kohle raus zu kommen
und natürlich holt sich die eu
kommission dieses meinungsbild ab auch
in deutschland und auch weil der neuen
bundesregierung und das ist
offensichtlich auch ein grund dafür
warum es immer wieder verzögerungen für
diesen vorschlag gegeben hat und nun ist
er da nun scheint sich die kommission
sehr sicher zu sein dass sie damit
durchkommt es bräuchte ja schon eine
super mehrheit der gegen 20 von 27
mitgliedstaaten müssten dagegen sein und
der ärger den es jetzt in deutschland in
österreich ein bisschen auch in spanien
gibt der scheint schon eingepreist die
bundesregierung die könnte sich sogar um
des koalitions willen
koalitionsfriedens willen enthalten und
trotzdem würde es diese super mehrheit
dagegen nicht geben also die taxonomie
die wirtin diesen grundzügen wohl kommen
die frage ist wie groß ist dann noch
ihre steuerungswirkung ihre
lenkungswirkung
klimaschützer zum beispiel seien tests
for future die warnen jetzt könnt ihr
das private geld eben nicht in die
erneuerbaren in die echten erneuerbaren
fließen und ein europaabgeordneter der
hat es heute so ausgedrückt wenn alles
nachhaltig ist dennis am ende nichts
nachhaltig dankeschön für die
einschätzungen nach brüssel und berlin
ja klimaschutz klimawandel oder auch die
ausstattung an schulen damit hatten wir
heute schon gleich zwei tagesaktuelle
themen in der sendung die ihre größte
bedeutung vor allem für die heute junge
generation und künftige generationen
haben denn sie tragen ja die folgen von
klimawandel oder auch bildungspolitik
haben auf die heutigen entscheidungen
aber eher wenig einfluss ganz abgesehen
davon dass es eh viel mehr ältere als
junge wähler und wählerinnen gibt brutal
in geld ausgedrückt mit rentenkürzungen
riskiert die politik mehr wählerstimmen
als mit maroden schulgebäuden das gilt
für den bundes bis zur kommunalpolitik
hinzu kommt dass die politik stärker
aufs heute als auch morgen schaut
immerhin hat die europäische union das
jahr
2022 zum jahr der jugend erklärt darauf
blickt stefanie dosch
kreistag sitzt des bundestages für diese
gruppe kein besichtigungs ziel in einem
trüben wintertag mehr symbol sie wollen
gehört werden auf der politischen bühne
über generationengerechtigkeit reden und
die probleme welche auf die jugend zu
wollen ich mache mir große sorgen weil
ich sehe dass die politik junge stimmen
nicht so ernst nimmt wie ich mir das
wünsche hätte ich da bei aller
präsentesten ist natürlich irgendwie der
klimawandel und wie wir da gerade so
noch die kurve bekommen aber natürlich
geht es auch irgendwie um themen wie
soziale gerechtigkeit aber auch was
passiert irgendwas am rentensystem in
der zukunft das klingt geschult ist es
auch der mit 20 weiteren
reiterinnen und mitstreitern bilden sie
den jugendrat 2017 wurde er gegründet
alle sind unter 25 jahren sie entwickeln
kampagnen
2021 mainz zum thema klima
und sie fordern vehement
generationengerechtigkeit
hier sehen uns eben als die
interessenvertretungen der jungen
generation und wir versuchen uns eben
auch im austausch mit
entscheidungsträger in eben für unsere
generation stark zu machen ausgewählt
und finanziert wird der jugendrat vom
kuratorium der generationen stiftung
dahinter verbergen sich wiederum kluge
köpfe der älteren generation
die idee entstand weil wir gemerkt habe
es sich viele alte und dazu zähle ich
mich auch schon sorgen machen um ihre
kinder und enkel ein schlechtes gefühl
haben und sehr viele der jungen angst
haben um ihre zukunft sich ohnmächtig
fühlen ihre lösung alt und jung
zusammenbringen wissen austauschen im
gespräch bleiben sehen wo die eine
generation der anderen helfen kann
treffen mit einem altgedienten
klimaforscher ich sehe es eher so dass
ich den jungen menschen geradezu
schuldig bin dass ich ein angebot mache
für dialog ich gebe mein wissen weiter
wenn es nachgefragt wird aber fahren
will ich eben wirklich ins gespräch
kommen dann erfahren wie die junge
menschen denken über die situation die
bedürfnisse der jungen generation
endlich genug berücksichtigen für sie
kernvoraussetzung für eine
zukunftsfähige demokratie man keine
generationengerechtigkeit in unserem
politischen system verankert dass auch
unsere demokratie massiv aber gerade
junge leute eben gerade ihr vertrauen in
demokratie verlieren fest steht krisen
ob heute oder net zukunft lassen sich
nur gemeinsam bewältigen mit allen
generationen zusammen
uns jetzt erstmal die nachrichten von
hall 12 die csu landesgruppe im
bundestag verschiebt wegen mehrere
corona fälle ihre klausurtagung sie
sollte am donnerstag beginnen aber unter
anderem hat sich landesgruppenchef
dobrindt angesteckt die klausur soll
bald nachgeholt werden
israel hat damit begonnen nun auch alle
einwohner ab 60 jahren und medizinisches
personal mit einer vierten impfdosis zu
immunisieren sofort das
gesundheitsministerium eine vierte
impfung bereits für immungeschwächte und
bewohner von pflegeeinrichtungen
genehmigt angesichts der sich stark
ausbreitenden omikron variante warnte
regierungschef bennett am vorabend vor
rasant steigenden neue infektionszahlen
die gesetzlichen krankenkassen
befürchten einen beitragsanstieg der
pflegeversicherung bereits im ersten
halbjahr 2022 der stellvertretende
vorstandsvorsitzende des
gkv-spitzenverbandes kiefer verwies in
der rheinischen post auf ein defizit von
zwei milliarden euro für 2021 und sagte
es gebe dringenden politischen
handlungsbedarf zur stabilisierung der
finanzlage werde nichts passieren sollte
so kiefer dann werde bereits im ersten
halbjahr eine beitragserhöhung von 0,3
prozentpunkten notwendig seien die fünf
ständigen mitglieder des
un-sicherheitsrats wollen gegen die
weitere verbreitung von atomwaffen
vorgehen in einer gemeinsamen erklärung
von frankreich großbritannien china
russland und den usa heißt es wir
betonen dass ein atomkrieg nicht
gewonnen werden kann und niemals geführt
werden darf man sei fest von der
notwendigkeit überzeugt der verbreitung
dieser waffen entgegen zu wirken
in hongkong hat citizen news eines der
meistgenutzten nachrichtenportale dort
seinen betrieb eingestellt dessen news
erklärte leider könne es seine
überzeugungen nicht mehr angstfrei in
die tat umsetzen erst ende dezember
hatte das pro-demokratische medium stent
news geschlossen nachdem hongkongs
behörden mehrere führende journalisten
der publikation hatten festnehmen lassen
im sudan ist ministerpräsident haben
überraschend zurückgetreten die
bundesregierung fordert wie die usa dass
das land wieder eine zivile regierung
bekommt am druck sagte er habe sein
versprechen nicht einhalten können eine
politische katastrophe zu verhindern er
war im oktober vom militär zunächst
entmachtet worden wurde aber auf druck
aus dem in und ausland wieder eingesetzt
gegen die regierungsbeteiligung des
militärs gibt es seit monaten proteste
in dem krisenstaat im nordosten afrikas
vor einem jahr feierten die briten den
beginn einer neuen ära nun nicht alle
briten das land war über den dreck sit
ja von anfang an gespalten aber die
versprechungen von boris johnson und
seinen mitstreitern waren groß befreit
von der eu sollte briten wieder great
gern werden selbstbestimmt zu neuem
wohlstand
ein jahr danach lässt sich an
premierminister im ständigen krisen
modus beobachten und das liegt nicht nur
an corona berichtet diana zimmermann
irgendwie ist bei boris johnson immer
wahlkampf scheinbar unzählige impf und
testzentren hat der premier in den
letzten eineinhalb jahren besucht heute
lange ungewöhnlich warmen precious und
wenn man sich den druck aufs
gesundheitssystem anschaut in den
nächsten wochen und vielleicht noch
länger und die anzahl der menschen die
ins krankenhaus müssen dann wäre es
wahnsinn zu sagen dass die sache schon
vorbei ist
der premier sieht erschöpft aus dabei
kann er eigentlich zufrieden auf das
letzte jahr zurück blicken
2021 sei ein hoch erfolgreiches
britisches impfprogramm im juni hatte
johnson die chefs der g 7 zu gast die
fußball-em nahm ein fulminantes ende in
london im november präsentierte sich
johnston als klimaretter doch 2022 wird
deutlich schwieriger die omikron welle
hat das land fest im griff
krankenhäusern droht der notstand weil
weite teile ihres personals krank oder
in isolation sind
johnson hat an weihnachten nur minimale
restriktionen verhängt weil er darauf
gewartet hat dass das gesundheitssystem
das auch so schafft wenn sich das als
falsch herausstellen sollte und das
wissen wir beide dann bekommt er da ein
dickes problem
das nächste problem ist die
wirtschaftslage steigende energiepreise
und inflation werden britische haushalte
im jahresschnitt um mindestens 1500 euro
ärmer machen und immer noch gibt es neue
folgen des brh exit seit dem 11 müssen
nun auch europäische exporteure
vollständige zorn erklärungen haben wenn
sie nach großbritannien liefern dass
rund die hälfte seiner lebensmittel aus
der eu bezieht
wir werden in den kommenden wochen
massive probleme sehen weil die
unternehmen plötzlich papieren dass es
sehr viel teurer und außerdem erheblich
komplizierter geworden ist mit
großbritannien zu handeln manche werden
sich anpassen andere werden einfach
aufhören mit uns zu handeln
auch die parteikollegen sind zunehmend
unbeeindruckt bei der jüngsten
abstimmung über sehr sanfte corona
maßnahmen stimmten fast 100 abgeordnete
gegen ihren eigenen premier sicher auch
rache für die insgesamt 40 kehrtwenden
die johnson seit amtsantritt vollzogen
hat
der wunde punkt des premiers ist dass er
die dinge nicht im griff zu haben
scheint und dass er seine
fraktionskollegen quält indem er sie
immer wieder über gesetze abstimmen
lässt die am nächsten tag zurücknehmen
muss sein verletzlicher punkt ist dass
sich der eindruck festsetzen könnte er
war zwar ein guter wahlkämpfer aber er
ist ein miserabler regierungschefs gaben
71 prozent der briten sind unzufrieden
mit den leistungen ihres premiers ben
johnson bei den regionalwahlen im mai
nicht ein weiteres wahlkampf kunst stück
liefert droht
2022 für den premier nicht nur ein
schwieriges sondern das letzte jahr zu
werden
tja mit schwierigen zeiten und
wirtschaft geht es bereits weiter die
inflation in der türkei ist nach
offiziellen angaben auf den höchsten
stand seit 19 jahren gestiegen laut
statistikbehörde erhöhten sich die
preise im dezember gegenüber dem
vorjahresmonat um durchschnittlich und
36 prozent von bethmann was bedeutet
eine solche teuerungsrate für die
verbraucher und für die türkische
wirtschaft insgesamt mehr für die über
84 millionen türken bedeutet das dass
sie immer weniger kaufkraft im
portemonnaie haben die regierung fordert
inzwischen die großen supermarktketten
des landes auf die preise zu senken
binnen jahresfrist wurden mail und
hühnerfleisch um 86 prozent teurer milch
und joghurt um rund 75% und brot um 54%
auf den wochenmärkten aber zweifeln
immer mehr türken wie dieser istanbuler
die offiziellen staatlichen zahlen an
die preise steigen jeden tag jede woche
vor and inzwischen gehe er davon aus
dass die preise um 100 prozent und mehr
zulegen während in aller welt
notenbanken auf steigende
inflationsrisiken mit steigenden zinsen
reagieren senkt die türkische
zentralbank fortlaufend die leitzinsen
auf geheiß von erdogan der türkische
präsident
auf ein kräftiges wirtschaftswachstum
eben weil sich die lehrer so verbilligt
hat und exporte jetzt viel attraktiver
macht manch einer fragt sich kann diese
rechnung aufgehen der dax rechnete heute
anders plus 136 punkte bedeutete den
sprung über die psychologisch wichtige
marke von 16.000 punkten und wir halten
fest das deutsche leitbarometer startet
gleich mal mit frischen schwung ins neue
jahr frank wittmann vielen dank
es gibt unwetterwarnungen des deutschen
wetterdienstes aktuell vor ergiebigem
dauerregen für teile von
baden-württemberg und von morgen früh an
vor orkanböen in teilen von
baden-württemberg in lagen über 1000
meter
bei der vierschanzen tournee war heute
in innsbruck qualifikation dort findet
der dritte wettkampf dieser tournee
statt morgen zu sehen im zdf gewonnen
hat die qualifikation der japaner ryo
kobayashi aus dem dsv team gelang markus
eisenbichler im training ein besonders
weiter sprung einen satz auf 139 meter
von markus eisenbichler aber kein neuer
schanzenrekord da es nur ein probesprung
war in der qualifikation sind das dann
nach einem verkorksten absprung und bei
rückenwind 20 meter weniger in der luft
habe ich gemerkt das ist jetzt nicht das
tragen der gefühle sondern eher bisserl
fallen das gefühl wenn claudia sektor
ausgehe es ist in ordnung karl geiger
landet nach seiner großen enttäuschung
beim neujahrsspringen heute auf platz
zehn in der qualifikation severin freund
ist mit 126 metern der stärkste deutsche
auf rang sechs wieder einmal nicht zu
bezwingen der führende in der
tournee-wertung review kobayashi mit
einer weite von 126 anhalt metern
gewinnt der japaner die qualifikation
fürs springen in innsbruck bei dem
morgen sieben deutsche starter dabei
sein werden
der spiegel feiert seinen 75 geburtstag
am vierten januar 1947 erschien der
erste titel der weit mehr war als eine
neue zeitschrift die man das damals
nannte nach angelsächsischem vorbild
setzte die redaktion einen neuen ton und
den anspruch den mächtigen auf die
finger zu schauen
1962 führte das mit einer
enthüllungsgeschichte über die
bundeswehr zur legendären spiegel affäre
erst wurden redakteure verhaftet später
musste der verteidigungsminister seinen
hut nehmen für die pressefreiheit in
deutschland war der ausgang damals einen
meilenstein
investigative enthüllungen wurden zum
markenzeichen einer redaktion deren
selbstbewusstsein dann allerdings einen
schweren knacks bekam zugefügt
ausgerechnet von einem der ihren aber
immerhin war es ein spiegel reporter der
in klassischer spiegel manier den
schwindel des kollegen aufdeckte ralf
zimmermann von siewert berichtet hinter
der schillernden fassade des hamburger
verlagshauses hat der fall renault cius
bis heute wunden hinterlassen vor drei
jahren deckte das blatt selbst auf wie
sehr sich in unzähligen artikeln des
vermeintlichen spiegel star reporters
class renault cius dichtung und wahrheit
vermischt und die veröffentlichten texte
mit qualitätsjournalismus nichts mehr zu
tun hatten wenn er sind von männern
begeistert die finden sich toll und dann
kommt einer mit solchen geschichten das
finden die super und so waren es eben
auch männer die den ja sehr lange
geschützt gestützt haben und es auch
nicht sehen wollten ihm ein reh lucius
ist passiert weil wir alle so testarossa
testosteron geschwenkt natürlich die
gegend laufen ich weiß es nicht es kann
sein
männer auf der jagd nach den besten
geschichten da kann es schon mal sein
dass man bestimmte standards außer kraft
gesetzt werden was frauen vielleicht in
der form nicht so passiert im fall
renault cius so meinen medienbeobachter
spiegelte sich symptomatisch eine
entwicklung die leicht verdauliches
geschichtenerzählen vor inhalte und
investigative recherchen gestellt habe
die im spiegel eigentlich über ihr hat
viele jahrzehnte ja fest ritualisierten
kontrollen die intern stattfinden
sollten bei diesen großen erzählern dann
nicht mehr gegriffen haben und die
kontrollen auch so zum auf null gedreht
wurden und nur noch die schnelle
knallige geschichte eigentlich immer das
entscheidende wahrscheinlich war der
spiegel einfach eine weile auch zu
erfolgreich und wurde dadurch ein
bisschen zu bequem
unsere los war für uns dann
eher so eine kleine erweckung keine
schöner aber immerhin wurden erweckt
dabei hatte der spiegel lange an seinem
ruf als sogenanntes sturmgeschütz der
demokratie gearbeitet in den 60er jahren
gingen einige redakteure gemeinsam mit
gründer legende rudolf augstein
vorübergehend in haft weil die regierung
unter bundeskanzler adenauer
landesverrat gewittert hatte
getragen hat
unendlich viele polit skandale deckte
der spiegel im laufe der jahrzehnte auf
doch das geschäft ist härter geworden
auch durch die konkurrenz auf digitalen
plattformen also die speerspitze ist ja
nun wirklich nicht mehr da gibt es
genügend andere medien und verbünde vor
allem ja die hier einen sehr klugen auch
international
agierenden recherchiert journalismus
entwickelt haben beim spiegel selbst
will man auch im hinblick auf die neuen
machtverhältnisse in berlin prinzipien
treu bleiben also der spiegel muss
eigentlich immer opposition gegenüber
den mächtigen sein egal wer gerade der
mächtige oder die mächtigen sind und das
schlimmste was passieren kann ist wenn
wir zusammen werden weil das passt gar
nicht zur marke nicht zur dna und das
ist auch nicht unser job übrigens eines
hat der spiegel zu seinem 75 geburtstag
geschafft nämlich einbußen im
printbereich durch ein dickes plus bei
online wett zu machen
das war es von uns im heute-journal
halte leicht das wetter und an das
montagskino 00 uhr meldet sich ingo
müller krause mit unserem heute
schneller update irgendwie da auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
frohes neues jahr die eindrucksvolle
wolken spirale von tiefem mitzieht
morgen weiter südwärts und zwingt das
tief annette auf eine südliche bahn
deswegen fällt morgen vor allen dingen
in süddeutschland viel regen dass mit
dem kräftigen regen geht allerdings
schon heute nacht los zunächst im
saarland und in rheinland-pfalz und bis
zum frühen morgen erreichen die
regenfälle dann auch den thüringer wald
und hier den bayerischen wald es gibt
allerdings auch eine region wo es heute
nach eher trocken bleibt nämlich
zwischen hannover berlin und der ostsee
küste im norden gibt es einige
regenschauer und davids ein recht
kräftiger wind aus südwestlichen
richtungen das wird eine milde nacht mit
11 bis 3 grad und morgen liegen dann die
höchsttemperaturen in norddeutschland
bei 6 bis 9 grad südlich des mains wird
es mit 10 bis 16 grad ungewöhnlich mild
für anfang januar und morgen schüttet
ist kräftig weiter am freundlichsten das
morgen wohl noch hier in schleswig
holstein und da der wind von südwest auf
west bis nordwest dreht kann es im
sauerland am nachmittag und abend
durchaus für schneeregen reichen es gibt
schwere sturmböen im schwarzwald mit 100
kilometer pro stunde schauen sie sich an
wie der regen hier weiter ostwärts zieht
er bleibt also nicht sehr lange an ort
und stelle hängen trotzdem können bis
mittwoch früh etwa 40 bis 70 liter regen
pro quadratmeter in den mittelgebirgen
zusammenkommen es droht also hochwasser
an kleineren bächen und flüssen in den
nächsten tagen wird es kälter für eine
schneedecke im flachland reicht aber
wohl nicht haben